how irritating would it be if I did all
of you like this here her another one
from series two not particularly
well-loved I wonder if people actually
go back and think of how uneven series 2
really was cuz boy okay so I already did
love and monsters which i think is
probably the one that gets more vehement
hatred than fear her does
I actually think fear her is worse
though I get why people dislike love and
monsters more and I think it's because
in addition to all the other things that
are wrong with it it's very structure
feels not like Doctor Who it makes it
really easy to single out because it's
got basically that's got a whole WTF
factor whereas fear her does at least
superficially feel like a Doctor Who
story the doc heard the dr. murrow's
arrive somewhere there is a problem
people are in danger they fix it so it
is on a basic surface level more
resembling of a standard Doctor Who
story than love and monsters which I
think makes that one an easier target
not to say that that like this is like
an overrated episode I don't know anyone
who thinks fear is very good but I do
think it's interesting that love in
monsters gets more hate but because the
reason I think this is worst is that at
least loving monsters I can look at and
go here are the kernel of the ideas and
the themes that had potential that could
have worked under other circumstances
having watched fear her again I don't
think there's anything to salvage from
this like all of it from the core
concept to the execution to the
performances to the pacing to the
resolution none of it like is anything
that I'd say okay we'll take that bit
and build something new around
like I would just scrap all of this so
in case you don't remember because I
actually think this one also sticks in
the mind a bit less than lovin monsters
did which is also another reason that
one probably gets more hate is that the
story on this one the dr. Rose show up
in the far-flung future of 2012 yeah
remember when that was futuristic I'm so
old uh in any case they get there and
there is this neighborhood where the
Olympic torch is going to be run through
in the very near future and basically
the people are living in terror children
have started disappearing and there's a
little girl up in her room that her
mother seems really kind of spooked by
and it turns out what's happening is how
do you even explain this an alien spore
had like a little seedling ship thing
that came too close to Earth got sucked
into the gravitation and crashed
that little spore alien thing is
normally part of a cluster of billions
and so it's feeling lonely it latches on
to this little girl who is also lonely
though for other reasons and then it
sort of empowers her with the ability to
draw the neighborhood kids and when she
does that they become trapped the real
kid becomes trapped in the drawings that
she made and also anything that she
doodles that doesn't have a real-world
equivalent that she's traveling into the
paper can also come alive oh and somehow
the Olympic torch is a universal symbol
of love and hope I mean hope maybe but
love like emphatically you said and the
fact that that's coming through helps
solve the it's really dumb guys like
that every level of this concept is dumb
and then the execution just sinks it all
the more I mean I'm a I marked it in my
in
TRO bit but I feel really bad for this
child actress because she's she's doing
the best she could but I think it was a
really bad decision to not in some way
modulate or dub her voice when when it
is this alien Spore thing that is meant
to be speaking through her head instead
they just have a child speaking in
whispers
complete with other big ugly brats and
yeah I can't take that seriously it's
not creepy it's not unsettling like I
think I can understand they should have
thought about it more but I think I can
see where the issue happened which is
that they didn't want to dub it over
with a more adult sounding voice because
the spohrer is also supposed to be a
child because what it's attempting to do
are childish solutions to its loneliness
so it can't be more mature than it's
it's thought process doesn't track
anymore so I get that but I mean just
get a voice act just get a car get an
adult woman cartoon voice actors who
normally voices kids and cartoons and
just to give it something different so
we're not stuck with this poor young
actresses puffy line readings it's it's
bad it is so painful and then then on
top of everything else it has the nerve
to try and be about like abusive
families and long-term emotional damage
and a parent's inability to help a child
cope like in a story this ridiculous
this absurd with a literal monster that
is a ball of scribbles that the doctor
erases with a pencil you have been nerve
to try and be poignant and have a
message on top of that what were they
thinking this like that to me was when
it truly went off the rails cuz I had
like I had vague memories of there was
the sketch of her father that she done
on the wall of her closet that was like
all threatening and monstrous and in
reality her father was dead and he was
abusive so like I remembered that but I
did not remember how hard this episode
tries to have that be like some sort of
emotional
punch or catharsis and it oh my god it
doesn't work like none of this works and
like I said the the whole idea of the
Olympic torch as a symbol of love what
you talk it's a similar competition like
I'm not saying there's not such a thing
as friendly competition theoretically
that's what the Olympics are but I then
I don't think of the Olympic torch and
think all a symbol of love what like it
said repeatedly look what isn't what is
even going on and the doctor Rose don't
get a heck of a lot to do either the
doctor gets taken out of commission
fairly early on it's not quite a doctor
light episode but it's close and then
Rose is left on her own choice Billie
Piper trying to do the best she can with
this preposterous script an insane story
and these actors who don't know how to
make this work not that I'm sure there
was any way it ever could have been made
to work all the while it's set in this
completely mundane setting which can
work very well for horror but none of
this is scary it's in when they try and
like milk the emotional damage that the
daughter had that one big part of why
that doesn't work is because right
before they try and do that we spend a
huge chunk of time dealing with the
Spore so like the daughters damage isn't
even what's been talked about for like
the last 20 minutes but now all of a
sudden we're gonna try and pay off a big
emotional impact for her thing Oh God
look these sorts of things where there
are things sort of circling around
children can work very well I think a at
its core not dissimilar concept at least
as far as a child who is impacting the
world in a negative way because of the
damage that that child is suffering is
later on down the line with night
terrors now I didn't like night terrors
as much as other people did but it works
I got a lot better than this that's
really the core concept of a child that
has powers way beyond you know what what
it should have for the kind of thought
processes and ways of think of thinking
what would work that a child has they
shouldn't have that level of power that
was a big part of what I liked about the
concept of the empty child back in
series 1 but
none of those sorts of underlying
factors that would make the idea of an
overpowered child are at play here so
none of it works it's just yeah like I
said I can look at love and monsters and
go okay I understand why this got made
why would like how early on in the
process looking at themes thinking of
general concepts why you would have
thought this was a good idea I can't
look at any piece of this thing and go
yeah I can see why you'd want to make
that bad episode and it doesn't help
that there's all these disjointed pieces
that also don't click together and form
anything other than a mess a big
scribbly mess like honestly that's what
the episode feels like the episode feels
like that scribble monster like somebody
who is just like crumple it up throw it
in the bin and somebody dug it out
filmed it yeah man yeah not good if you
uh hadn't gathered that already fear her
what did you think about this thing
hooey whatever you thought drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about it all a bunch of stuff to do
as well there's uh the Oh buttons and
links is linked to my patreon I actually
just restructured the rewards and the
tears a little bit on there so maybe
check that out if you haven't in a while
and you know other stuff to look at I've
got a peel box and other sorts of stuff
all sorts of links you don't want to
click on any of them that is okay too
because at the end of the day folks
you're the council I just run the
meeting so until next time this council
is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]